good morning John ever since your pants
got hacked I've been thinking a lot
about the apocalypse now you might think
that there's a big difference between a
bunch of script kiddies and camp chuck
could bringing down your pan and the end
of the world as we know it but it turns
out some surprising similarities but
before we get into that let me explain
to you the anatomy of the attack on your
pants if you want to leave the terms in
the following description explained just
pause the video there will be
definitions on the screen let's start
out for those who are very confused
right now with your pants okay so first
a hacker discovered a vulnerability in
the vBulletin software that runs your
pants not hacker then created an exploit
for that vulnerability at that point a
zero-day exploit that he or she could
use to exploit this vulnerability the
hacker released his exploit probably in
the form of a very simple script that
would allow anyone with even moderate
computer knowledge the ability to hacked
your bad these scripts were run by an
army of underlings known as script
kiddies the script would attempt to own
the server's pull off passwords that can
be sold on the black market and use the
servers for sending our spam stuff like
that our white hat security expert Sam
Rudd stopped the infiltration before any
user data was compromised so everything
is safe except the data that was made up
your pants a big hunk of it
unfortunately has been lost so if you
understood all that without having
pressed pause and read definitions than
you're good if you didn't go back and
watch it read and understand all those
definitions think it's going to need to
because we are on the cusp of a
fundamental shift in the way that crime
and war happened so you're gonna need at
least a basic knowledge of cyber warfare
and cyber crime last night for example
someone or a group of someone's
identifying themselves with a hacker
group Anonymous totally hacked the
Syrian Ministry of Defense website and
put up like a message of solidarity for
the people of Syria this isn't really
super grand this is more of a hacktivist
thing so yeah what Anonymous does is
high-profile yeah it's kind of like sort
of weirdly cool that they can do these
things that's not what keeps me up at
night and let me tell you this stuff
does keep me up at night Russian mafia
has a hacking team so sophisticated that
it has revenues in the billions of
dollars they have collected so many
credit cards that they can no longer
sell them because criminals are like we
have too many credit card numbers I
don't know what to do with these Chinese
hackers maybe sponsored by their own
government I've been hacking governments
and private corporations for years and
has stolen billions of dollars of
intellectual property what I find
scariest of all is a piece of mal
we're called Stuxnet no computer virus
has ever used more than one window zero
day exploit Stuxnet had full Stuxnet
infected thousands of computers running
industrial equipment all over the world
but it only activated in one place the
centrifuges refining uranium in Iran
well all of the readouts remain calm and
everything looked completely normal
those centrifuges spun out of control
and exploded who built Stuxnet that's
one of the things about cyber warfare no
one knows where these things come from
almost certainly it was a multinational
project spearheaded by the United States
government but no one took credit for it
another problem is that this is kind of
like dropping a new kind of bomb on your
enemy along with the plans for how you
built the bomb you don't want to do this
because now the code for Stuxnet is
freely available on the Internet and
with the right knowledge it can be
modified to break down oil pipelines
shut down power plant or open the
floodgates of a dam now I am not
generally an alarmist
I don't usually worry about these types
of things but this is pretty scary so
yes I'm glad that Iran's nuclear weapons
program has been set back significantly
and I don't know if it was worth
creating an entirely new type of warfare
to do it because I worry about the
attacks themselves but I also worry
about the legislation that will be
created to protect us one because the
legislation will probably ruin a lot of
what's great about the internet and two
because the legislation will never be
effective because there's no way that
the professional arguers in Congress
will ever be less than 42 steps behind
the hackers I wanted to talk about this
because I want more people know about it
but unfortunately I don't have any like
solution we just gonna cross our fingers
hackers or smart people hopefully smart
enough to know that destroying the world
is a freakin bad idea John I'll see you
on Wednesday